yeah [ __ ] a Trump so now that Donald
Trump has made America great again he's
gonna make the world a better place
- but is the world ready for that here's
Trump pulling a Gordon Ramsay at the UN
about a tell'em that their menu sucks my
administration has accomplished more
than almost any administration in the
history of our country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay laugh if you must use small
meaningless bureaucrats what have you
done lately besides boozing on our dime
and chasing hookers love it or hate it
Trump's the leader of the free world and
he's ready to give the planet a little
tough love Germany will become totally
dependent on Russian energy if it does
not immediately change course moving
forward
we are only going to give foreign aid to
those who respect us OPEC nations are as
usual ripping off the rest of the world
and I don't like it
nobody should like it nobody should like
it you know he's like the American Santa
he's telling the world who's been
naughty and nice but everybody's naughty
everybody on his list is naughty and
he's just getting started I don't like
what's happening in Cuba and I certainly
don't like what's happening in Venezuela
Iran's gonna come back to me and they're
gonna make a good deal I think maybe
that deals you never know
the Emmons a mess Syria's a mess not
happy with OPEC I like China and I like
President Xi a lot I think he's a friend
of mine he may not be a friend of mine
anymore he's got an opinion on everyone
to him earth is just another location
for celebrity apprentice
Cuba you're fired and of course there's
that relationship with China they flirt
that they play hard to get it's like a
geopolitical version of Ross and Rachel
from friends he was saying that China
has total respect for Donald Trump and
for Donald Trump's very very large brain
for a minute there for a minute there
you thought it wasn't going to be brain
that pause he did was amazing and houki
who can forget the letter the
magnificent letters he said this is
actually a groundbreaking letter this is
an incredible this is a historic letter
he wrote me two of the most beautiful
letters I've received two letters from
chairman Kim they're incredible letters
they're they're letters that are
magnificent that is some letter
I think the letters D and T and boy he
gave it to the Kurds excuse me you said
we're from where buthow media network
from Kurdistan region OK ROCK
I'm a Kurd great people thank you sir
crazy president mister thank you
are you occurred
you occurred I'm just gonna ask that to
everybody and even Canada didn't get out
without a kick in the cranberries did
you reject a one-on-one meeting with a
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
yeah I did why cuz his tariffs are too
high and he doesn't seem to want to move
and I've told him forget about it forget
about like look he's talking to his
plumber not an actual world leader
Canada anyway so who's great now you
know who's great now we Drake now that's
right which is why he's now into
changing the world like a real estate
developer from Queens he's done with one
project United States and he's moving on
to another and get this and this is
really really important none of the
stuff he's talking about involves
military force and shouldn't that be
something that lefties embrace and love
about this guy instead of flexing
military muscle he toys with the failing
New York Times stand up go ahead the
failing New York Times stand up go ahead
I think ABC CBS NBC The Times or they're
all going to endorse me because if they
don't know we can't imagine that at all
so all in all he realizes for America to
be greater you know
earth needs a little work too and he's
willing to lead the enterprise
peacefully what could be the
possibilities sunday sunday sunday get
ready for the most globally electrifying
event ever versus the
he's made America great and now jonald
the diplomatic mastermind Trump is
taking the battle International by
improving those two rocks on Easter
Island turning Siberia into a meat
locker for Trump steaks at advanced on
Michelangelo's David mopping up Venice
replacing windmills in Holland with coal
mines making Big Ben a digital clock
fitting Mount Everest with an escalator
decorating the Great Wall of China with
Bob Ross paintings plus he's fixing the
Leaning Tower of Pisa with a team of
nine and don't miss the all-american
finale will Trump finally fixed the
broken Liberty Bell or put a more
awesome face on Mount Rushmore get your
tickets now to find out the first 100 s
the truck versus the UN World reboot
awesome ization extravaganza
[Music]
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's get she's so
bright the North Star calls her for
advice attorney and Trump campaign
Advisory Board member Madison Jesse Otto
and he's so smart it hurts Washington
Times opinion editor and Fox News
contributor Charlie heard she's so
bright she moonlights as moonlight
National Review reporter captain his
neighbors all have earthquake insurance
former WWE Superstar my massive sidekick
Tyrus
Charles it's so interesting when there
are people talking about that press
conference and they act like it's some
kind of weird freak show and I'm looking
at it I'm going I'm watching a guy with
an incredibly nimble mind bounce all
over every single issue and and talk
about fixing them as though it's a
construction project but also I mean the
guy's comedic timing yeah
is just it's killer and when he did the
thing about talking about how great the
administration is and everybody laughed
yeah and and in this room everybody left
they left at the exact right times the
guy totally gets it yeah it's that it's
that humor that that that and and of
course they're all these despots in the
world and in the room who did who got it
just proving that that of course the
press has less of a sense of humor than
despots around the world good no but but
the other thing is that basically the
attack on Donald Trump right now is that
he's not perfect
that's what upsets them so when he goes
and he talks he meets with Kim jong-un
Kim jong-il the the complaint is oh well
you haven't gotten peace fast enough
it's not absolutely the guy can't win
and they constantly and they did this
throughout the campaign and they're
continuing to do it they constantly move
the goalposts
you know Charlie brings up a good point
which is rare Madison the media is wrong
about Trump in the fact in potat because
they think that the world finds him
comical or weird but I I have a theory
that a lot of the world isn't like
Manhattan the world is pretty old-school
alpha they're like 30 years 40 years
back when people would know when the
world leaders were like Trump so he's
kind of entertaining and refreshing or
something that's my theory it free built
feel free to ignore it and answer the
own question that might be in your mind
I mean I think he was very funny yet his
press conference I think he's hilarious
a lot of the times but I think he's very
successful and that's the thing that the
media fails to report on yeah you know
look at everything that he did
throughout the UN this week it was an
extremely successful week they signed a
revised trade agreement of South Korea
open trade talks with Japan of course
going after China who no president
before in 25 years has really gone after
for their unfair
trade practices they said you know he
could never have peace in certain areas
guess what look what he's doing with
North Korea it's only the beginning
there and so I think people are just
ignoring the fact that he's been
extremely successful they're judging him
on words instead of actions and results
okay cat he's not a neocon this is god I
mean like let's face it he's change
y'all he's changing in the world without
bombs and that I mean that's kind of
what I would call progress maybe I
that's one of the things that I do like
about him is that he tends to want to
use diplomacy and talking and making
deals rather than just going to war with
everyone yeah and I thought that that
was something that was very interesting
in the general election when he was
running against Hillary Clinton even
though she was a Democrat yeah he was a
neo Democrat yes
so she certainly would have gone I think
we would be at war right now in places
that we're not at war if we had had
Hillary Clinton as president instead of
BB with Canada we might be at war with
Canada yeah Australia what is the one
time the establishment applauded Donald
Trump it's when he bomb Syria it's the
only time yeah exactly they love a good
boy I do not I do not care for that you
did not care for that did not care for
that anything else any thoughts I mean I
want to talk about Ross and Rachel again
okay go ahead I just don't think I
should have taken that long for them to
work it out yeah I did that is true oh
it's almost getting a strata ring of
applause
[Applause]
Cyrus I look at what he speaks to the
world and when he when he gives his
speeches a lot like someone who just
beat the rap on a case and everyone who
testified against him is at the barbecue
and he just showed up yeah he knows
every one of them's I know what every
one of you did but I'm here and so the
laughing is a lot of nervous laughing
yeah yeah it's that's true he's coming
from a place of power and I think he's
probably one of the I can't remember a
president who chose to use it mm-hmm
yeah listen to me when I speak yeah and
if you don't you're gonna wish you had
there's very underlying it's he kind of
talks him away very similar like when
somebody borrows money for me and they
don't pay it back yeah
yep he appeals to your senses like say
for example Joe you like walking Joe
will say yes I do
well for you to continue to do so you
need to pay me the money I lent you plus
10% that is how he talks to the world
and I think they get it
Joe got it yeah yeah is he walking Joe
yeah he will be fun he's healing nicely
in an undisclosed location